hi everyone welcome to my talk on a
practical guide to graph databases
before we get started here I guess has
anybody here use the graph database
before which one did you use neo anybody
else so so this is a new topic for most
people I mean so let me tell you a
little bit about myself my name is Dave
Mac burger I'm an architect and a
architect in a full-stack developer I've
been developing for full-stack software
for about 20 years now that's everything
from high performance low latency
distributed data platforms through
high-performance web apps built on top
of those who you know standard line of
business and enterprise applications for
the past couple years
my focus is building on building out
distributed high-performance big data
platforms pretty particularly those
built on top of graph databases that's
why I'm here to talk to you because
graph databases are kind of my thing
they're the thing I really enjoy working
with and I like helping other people use
them to their fullest potential so for
the past couple years I had been working
as a consultant basically through a
variety of companies from financial
sector to oil and gas to bioinformatics
helping them use graph databases to the
inside their systems to their fullest
potential currently I'm the chief
Software Architect for a company called
gene by gene we are a bioinformatics
company that specializes in genetic
genealogy and we're using a graph day
we're basically working on breaking up
our monolithic sequel server net
application and as part of that we're
using a graph database to help out where
it makes the most sense to speed up that
process so as I said what we're here to
talk about today is graph databases so
why well graph databases are a hot thing
they're probably the hottest thing in
data stores right now I know data stores
are not you know the sexiest technology
out there but as we all know having your
data store work well solid and fast is
great the best thing you can have with
your data store is that nobody knows it
exists that it just works for everybody
so this chart shows basically different
types of data stores and their
popularity since January of 20
13 in that time the prom popularity of
graph databases has jumped eight hundred
percent I've been working with graph
databases almost exclusively for three
years or so and I can tell you in the
past year they've actually gotten
significantly more traction than they
had in the previous two years that I
worked with them previous two years
there was a lot of companies that were
working and using them as a little proof
of concept little research projects
things like that now companies are
coming out and they're using them in
full-on production mode especially with
the release of Amazon Neptune and I as
cosmos DB's gremlin API it's really
provided kind of legitimacy to them as a
first-class datastore that people are
really seriously considering for
projects are working on so you can't
have a car talk about graph databases
without talking a little bit about graph
theory because graph databases are based
on graph theory graph theory is that
mathematical construct we probably all
learned and met back in university and
forgot it's quickly thereafter but
basically what it comes down to it was
invented by this guy Leonardo Euler and
the famous seven bridges of königsberg
his problem and basically what it did is
it came up with a system allowing you to
abstract out basically it was allowing
you to abstract out real world concepts
into abstract nodes nodes and
relationships between things which are
called nodes as a nodes and edges in
graph in graph theory why does that
matter well a graph data story it's a
type of no sequel datastore and it's
based on using those structures to build
efficient methods to traverse and
represent those relationships so when
you look at it and what I think of is
the no sequel spectrum you go from the
data complexity of being the most simple
to the most complex and the complexity
really comes down to how data is related
to one another the simplest and you have
a key value store this is your your
Redis your react your DynamoDB your
aerospike it's basically where your data
has no relation other than to itself you
get a little bit more complex you want
to have some relations between other
fields other properties you get
something like a wide column or a column
oriented data store this is something
like Cassandra Apache HBase or Google
Cloud BigTable get a little more complex
as far as relationships go you get a
document database the document allows
you to have complex relationships with
inside a document and even some minor
joining across documents but
when it comes down to it each entity is
a document itself then you get to the
relational database the relational
database is what we all know we've all
done used for many many years we're all
very familiar with how they work in the
basic constructs around them this is
your sequel servers you're Postgres is
your Oracle's you're my sequels what we
all probably use every day in our normal
day-to-day work and then you have graph
graph allows you to deal with come more
complex relationships that are
effectively and efficiently stored in a
relational database what why is that
what do I mean when I say that I mean
relations are in the name of a
relational database they should be very
good at actually storing them well the
truth that when it comes down to it is
in a relational database your relations
are not first-class citizens your
relations cannot have properties and
metadata to themselves whereas in a
graph database they are first-class
citizens they're allowed to maintain
their own med data in their own
properties as their relate as they're on
that relationship itself as opposed to
having to do something like a bridge
table so in you know in a state and a
standard ordered product sort of order
system in a relational database you have
an order table you would have a products
table and then you have what I tend to
call like a bridge table that would
contain the order details it would be
maybe the quantity the order day the
number of product you know the price
paper product in a graph database you're
actually able to eliminate that need for
that third table and have just a node
that represents the order and no that
represents the product and an edge
between them that is that the product
was ordered on that edge you're able to
put that metadata about how that actual
you know the product the quantity that
was ordered the date it was ordered
things like that on that edge itself and
use that when you're doing what's called
a traversal which is the the graph
equivalent of a query to pull that data
back out and filter on it so what why
would you use a graph database well you
go on Google you'll find tons of
examples of different use cases for
graph databases these are just a couple
that I thought I would highlight the
first one here is network analysis this
is your friends of friends problem this
is we all been on Facebook we've all
been on LinkedIn we've all seen the you
know people you may know or people that
you know know this person sort of thing
that that's a network analysis problem
this is also referred to as the six
degrees of Kevin Bacon problem you know
every actor is related to Kevin Bacon
within six degrees of separation this is
that that's this sort of problem graph
databases are very good at solving this
sort of problem
because they're very good at traversing
those relationships between things
you'll hear me say that a lot doing this
talk because it's really kind of if you
if you keep one key fact out of this
that's probably the most important thing
if your problem is about traversing or
how things are related then graph
database may be a good solution to your
problem
you know another common one is a
recommendation engine because a
recommendation engine is all about
pattern matching and finding
relationships between things because a
recommendation what do you want to do
when you build a recommendation you want
to find a profile of someone who's
bought items that are similar to your
items and then find the other things
that they've purchased that you haven't
purchased so you can give them a more
accurate representation or a more
accurate recommendation of what they
should get fraud detection on fraud
detection is a very common use case for
a graph database because fraud detection
at its heart is really comparing a set
of known transactions to a set of known
fraudulent transactions and seeing how
much they overlap and how similar they
are to one another one that kind of
surprised me when I first got into it
was master data management you wouldn't
necessarily think of master data
management as a graph problem but it
actually fits in the graph space pretty
well why is that because graph wouldn't
in master date a man is a problem when
you really get down to it is all about
figuring out that entity a in system a
equals company B and system B equals
entity C and in system C so it's all
about relating those items together so
when you make a change to one you're
able to link them together to find out
how that though all those things are
talking about the same one item so now
that we know a little bit about graph
databases I wanted to talk a bit about
the graph ecosystem I call it a
ecosystem because it's large the craft
ecosystem is very large and it's rapidly
growing this slide up here I last count
when I was putting it together I'm not
sure I got all of them but there was 43
different graphed data stores up there
this when I originally built this slide
a couple of weeks ago I have I can't I
knew a 32 which I thought was pretty
impressive on myself I threw it out to
some of the people I know on Twitter
that also worked the graph databases
within a day I got another 10 that I'd
never even heard of on this so that's
what I mean it's a very large in a very
rapidly growing ecosystem and a lot I
mean a lot of these have been around for
a long time a lot of these are brand new
so it's continually evolving and each
one is
print from the others in certain
distinct ways so in order to kind of
help out with this talk I decided to put
him into some big buckets these are the
buckets that I chose if you ask for
different people in the graph space
you'll get four different sets of block
gifts but the ones I basically chose
were the big buckets where it's either a
graph framework or it's a graph database
and then inside a graph database it's
either an RDF triple store or a labeled
property model graph we'll go into the
details of what those things mean here
in a second the first one to talk about
is the difference between a database and
a framework when I'm talking about a
graph database I'm talking about a
system where the data is both persisted
and processed by that system this is
very similar to what we all think of
this kind of a sequel database or other
relational database it's good for
real-time querying and it handles both
transactional and analytical type
workloads on the other hand you have a
framework the biggest difference in my
mind between a framework and a database
is that a framework does not persist the
data it just processes it using graph
algorithms so the data for a framework
is loaded from something like your data
Lake your data warehouse your Hadoop
file system is a pretty common one that
allows it to work on enormous size data
sets because you're just loading the
data from something else and usually
running it on a distributed analytics
engine something like a spark it's
allowed to work on enormous data sets
that are too big to fit even on a
cluster of servers that you would need
for something to run them that same
analytical work loading it you know in
an actual database itself so because you
have to load the data because it takes
time to do that it's really on
frameworks are really useful for
analytical workloads not really
transactional workloads when you get
down to databases there's two basic
types of databases there's an RDF triple
store in a label property graph or a
label property model graph in an already
F triple store each entity in in the
graph is a triple that triples contains
a subject object predicate that that's
what consists that's what your triple
consists of this comes from the Semantic
Web it's actually got aa there's a w3c
standard for our it's for RDF the
resource description framework RDF grow
data stores when I think of them I think
that they're great for inferring
relationships between things that you
main
know that their relationship existed
prior you on the other side you have
labeled property model graphs labeled
property model graphs work on two
different types of entities they work on
nodes and edges when it works on nodes
and edges you have nodes edges they also
have properties that can be associated
with either nodes or edges and this
concept of a label a label is associated
with a node or an edge to give it a type
so it's kind of like a schema thing
where you're able to assign nodes of
specific types with specific properties
they're great for can basically label
property monographs are great for
efficiently being able to traverse
relationships that you already know you
can do inference to a degree with
labelled property model graphs but
really when it comes down to it they're
better at working with other better at
rapidly and effectively traversing data
that are relationships that you know so
here's an example of the same same data
model using in an RDF triple store in a
labeled property model graph so if you
start here at this node that says Bob on
the on the RDF side you know if I want
to find out what what is it that Bob
drive so well Bob drives a Ford and a
Ford is a car so I'm able to refer infer
from that relationship that Bob drives a
car on the other hand on the labeled
property graph side you'll see I have a
node that if type person where the name
has it has a property that the name is
Bob an edge that an edge that's directed
towards car and that cars make is a Ford
so I'm able to both so as you can kind
of see they both show the same
information in slightly different
manners so now that we know a little bit
about the different types of data data
stores are out there how do I get my
data out I mean that's kind of the next
question once I know what the different
things are how do I get my dad out graph
query languages is an area where the
graph ecosystem starts to get a little
complicated and I say it's complicated
because in there R is no standard graph
query language across all of the things
like there is for sequel I when you
write sequel for one database there
might be slight differences across
databases but in general it's very
transparent very easy to move from one
to the other with slight modifications
to your queries graph data stores that's
not true as you see up here I had kind
of bucketed into file
different uh types of graph Korean
languages the first one being sparkle
Sparkle is probably the only one up
there that I would say is is a standard
for RDF Tripp well it's the only one
that's out there that I would say is
sort of a standard because it's the
standard for RDF triple stores it's part
of that w3c standard so it's wellspect
out and respected by any of the RDF
triple stores that I'm aware of as I
said it comes from the it comes from the
Semantic Web and it's that w3c standard
when you get to label property
monographs
the it gets a lot murkier as far as how
you get your data the most common one
you'll probably run into and what neo4j
uses is a language called cipher so
cipher was actually created by neo4j to
query their datastore I think it was
about three two and a half three years
ago they open sourced the site the spec
into what's called open cipher so it's
now an open-source spec that's there's a
committee that decides it it's a very
declarative language so it's very much
like sequel it's probably the easiest of
the labeled property monograph ones to
use for a new person coming on board and
because of that and the popularity of
neo4j it's probably the most popular one
that you'll find out there in the wild
it's certainly the one you'll find the
best documentation on the next most most
common one you'll run into is gremlin
gremlin is part of the Apache tinker pop
project which is a very interesting and
complex project because it's a database
a graph query language and a graph
engine all at the same time it's both an
imperative and a declarative language
you most often find it the imperative
syntax used as the declarative syntax is
a little bit complex to get working
correctly it's a very powerful language
it's very composable you can basically
get any information you out with out of
it that you need out of your graph but
it's got a steep learning curve it takes
quite a bit of effort to really get very
efficient at writing it it's the one
that's implemented by I believe the most
number of data stores out there I
believe there's more that there's more
that implement tinker the tinker pops
gremlin then cipher but I said the this
is a constantly evolving landscape so
that number may be changing that's what
both cosmos DB and M AWS Neptune use is
they're 13 core pop enabled
the other one you'll find out there on a
few data stores is graph QL
in my mind graph QL is better used to as
a query language for rest endpoints than
really a query language for graph
databases but there are a few graph
databases that use it as the native
query language to get data out and the
last one is just a big bucket of kind of
everything else there's a lot of data
stores out there that implement their
own specific data store specific graph
query language they're almost always
based off of some sort of sequel but
they're specific to a single system
there is a movement that's out there
very recently called gql which stands
for graph query language is is to
basically an attempt to create a
standard for property model graph query
languages much like sparkle but when I
say it's very new I mean within the past
month this proposals come out so there's
really other than a semi agreement
across companies to make it work there
isn't any actual there's no
implementation of it yet so what you're
seeing here is a very simple graph query
written in all five different languages
all five different languages up there
this is a simple I want to find a friend
of my friends or I want to find all the
friends of my friends I should say so
the first one you'll see here is sparkle
one of the things about Sparkle is
because it comes from the Semantic Web
every entity and sparkle is a URI so the
very first part here where you see this
prefix fo AF basically that's saying
anywhere you see fo AF and your query
prefix this on top of it are before it
so it makes your query significantly
easier to read because I don't want to
read HTTP colon slash slash every time
I'm trying to write out a property name
so basically a prefix is that onto
everything and then it's a simple select
we're very very sequel like in syntax in
order to pull your data back right below
that what you'll see is cypher as you
can see it's a very declarative language
where you're basically saying I want to
match things that match this pattern
you'll notice that anything this has
surounded brackets represents a node
anything that has anything that has
square brackets represents the late
on an edge so it's saying find me a
person then find me then go out the
friend edge what the start is there the
start to is it's actually saying go out
the friend edge twice so I'm gonna go
from a person across the friend edge to
another person and then across a friend
edge again to another person and then
return me those that person's name below
that you'll see gremlin in it's
imperative syntax gremlin has this
concept where it's all the air queries
and gremlin will either start with a GV
or GE what that stands for is basically
in my graph give me all the vertices or
give me all the edges and then it then
filters down based on that based on the
next what are called steps so it's
basically saying find me everything that
has a label of person and then go out
the friend edge two times each each item
here or each thing here is called a step
in gremlin terms dee doop my values and
then return me the name graph QL as you
can see is very JSON in nature it's
basically a JSON specification of the
data you want to receive back on the
last I'm done here is I believe Orient
DB sin sequel syntax so a lot of them
look very similar to this but as I said
these are kind of very datastore
specific so they may be different based
on which one you're looking at the last
part of the graph ecosystem I kind of
wanted to touch on was the different
visualization options out there now that
you know what the basis of your database
is you know how to get the data out of
your data store what do you do with it
how do you see it graph data in it by
its very nature is very visual I mean
with sequel data you can pretty much see
you can see it and you could see it in a
you know rows of data on a screen for
all that really matters because it's
very it's it's tabular in that nature
graph date is all about relationships
between things to being able to
visualize those relationships is really
important in order to be able to
effectively understand what's going on
there's a couple of desktop tools out
there once open source called gessie the
other one out there is a relatively
newcomer it's called Arcade Analytics
they both build best desktop tools or
well okay it's actually a web based tool
but it allows you to basically enter
if we work with your with your data to
basically play with it and figure out
what's going on and dig into it and real
interactive sort of thing on a desktop
so it's more for data exploration then
kind of an end user system in the middle
you have one that that supports both has
both a web tool and a desktop tool Tom
Sawyer software and Lync curious are the
two most common ones that I've run into
in this space and then you have ones
that you're very good for basically
doing web visualizations d3 probably
most people here that do web development
is probably heard of d3 d3 actually has
some really powerful tools for
integrating with graph databases
Cambridge intelligence has a tool called
key lines which is a basically it's not
graph specific but it's very heavy to
leaning towards graph visualizations
Sigma GIS and why works or another or
two other companies out there that also
have very deep integrations into
visualizing graph data so what do I mean
by visualizing graph data well
visualizing graph data is really really
thought about the two up on the right of
the screen here isn't these I always
call these no charts basically you're
showing nodes and edges whose the
relationships in between one thing I
want to make sure that we trap you don't
necessarily fall into is just because
you're grout your data is a graph
doesn't mean you need to represent it to
your end-user graph as a graph and
that's where the one on the Left comes
in this is actually a demo that
Keeneland's puts out that's basically
hotspots of crimes and I think Chicago
over time as you can see the data
underneath it is powered by a graph but
the data as you're seeing it makes more
sense to user as a heat map so to use or
not to use a graph database that's the
question we're all here to answer
probably so everything is a graph if you
walk out if you go look on the internet
you'll see this is written up there a
lot this concept that everything is a
graph my colleagues and I have been
guilty of kind of promoting this concept
that everything is graphs well it's true
everything in the world is pretty much a
graph because everything's things
related to other things which is what a
graph makes up what we really should
have done when talking about it from a
tech
perspective is added but that doesn't
mean you should use the graph to solve
it
graph databases are great in certain
scenarios and they're not great in other
scenarios it's not that you can't do it
in a graph database it's just probably
not the optimal tool for many use cases
so so how do you know which ones it's
good for and which ones it's not well it
really comes down to exploring the
questions it's you know doing some deep
exploration into the questions you're
trying to answer will really help you
learn or help you not only learn how to
better solve your problem but lead you
towards the right answer for the data
story you want to use for to solve that
type of problem so let's say you want to
do a search or a selection type problem
you know give me everyone that works in
a specific company or find me everyone
the first name like John or find me all
stores within 200 miles of you know Oslo
Norway well this is you should probably
just use your relational database or if
you have a search server something like
an elastic search or a solar there farm
were out there far more tuned to you
answer this sort of question very
effectively and efficiently let's say
you want to talk about you want to have
a related data question you want to find
you know what's the easiest way for
median should B be introduced into this
executive maybe you want to you know get
introduced to an executive in your
LinkedIn you know and you look at your
LinkedIn contacts and you want to find
out how to get between two people or how
do two people inside a company know each
other you know how has a company this
company related to that company inside
my CRM system well this is this is where
a graph answers your question I mean if
you listen to what I said the word
you'll hear come up over and over again
is relations relations are really what
graph databases are about aggregation
queries I mean how many of these do we
all write in probably a single week you
know how many companies are in my system
what are the average sales for each day
or you know with the number of
transactions processed in a day I always
think of these sorts of questions as
these these are executive dashboard
questions these are the type of things
you want to show up on an exec you on a
dashboard that gets surfaced up to the
executive level so they can quickly see
how the system is working this is where
your relational database shines this is
what relational databases are optimized
to do is these sorts of queries use your
relational database where it makes the
most sense
pattern-matching you know who is who has
a similar profile to me maybe this is
your product recommendation who you know
who who has a similar shopping pattern
to my shopping pattern or does this
transaction look like it's fraudulent or
is this user the same as this user well
this one's a little more complicated
this one can really depend it could be a
graph it could be your search server if
I had to look at these three questions
I'd say the first who probably leaned
towards a graph to me and the last one
probably leans towards using a search
server something like an elastic search
to answer that question can you answer
all these questions with the graph
absolutely is it necessarily the right
solution to your problem maybe maybe not
clustering centrality and influence you
know who's the most influential person I
know on LinkedIn you know what equipment
in my network is going to be has the
largest impact if it breaks you know
what parts fail at the same time
this is right this is in in the center
of the wheelhouse where we're graph
databases exceed the abilities of
something like a relational database
these are this is where graph database
is really shine is these sorts of
questions as well as the other ones I
talked about but this one to me is far
and away the easiest one to answer what
yes this is a graph that you want to do
you want to use I should say so you're
still not sure so what you see here is
some work based on a flow chart that my
colleague dr. Denis Gosnell worked on
and it's pretty much you know what kind
of questions you're answering are you
answering those executive dashboarding
questions you know if you're answering
those executive dashboarding questions
use your relational database it probably
it's optimized for handling those it
there's been around for 40 years all the
tools exist all the tools work with them
use those to the best of their ability
are you dealing with more data
exploration questions or more trying to
find insight in intelligence in your
data well then you may want to look at a
graph so what are you going to do with
it then if you you know you want to use
a graph database you don't know what
kind of questions you can answer are you
gonna answer questions that are really
about analyzing large portions your data
are you gonna load all of the
connections on LinkedIn into your graph
and then try to find who is the person
that has the most influence across the
entire system well if you're gonna do
that sort of questioning where you're
really looking at large sections or the
entirety of your graph and we're going
to answer it that's where a graph
framework comes
those sorts of questions are are optimal
ones to use a graph framework to help
answer or are you trying to do one that
I want to find out how Bob's related to
Jane or James related to Tom and I want
to show the answers to an end user and
say a CRM system or something like that
but sort of storing and querying
operation is where a graph data store
you know graph database itself is
probably the right tool if you're trying
to do both at the same time you need to
go back to the beginning and better to
find your questions because you're
trying to answer two different types of
questions with the same solution as I
said I spent a lot of the past couple of
years working as a consultant and the
one I see more often than not is this
one which is I sold this to management
as a graph problem so we're using a
graph database to solve it as I said you
can solve any of these problems we've
talked about with a graph database it
just may not be your optimal solution
are you still confused well do you care
about the relationships between entities
more than the entities themselves if you
were gonna model this in your relational
database would this take multiple joins
you know five or six joins to get the
data out or you would you have to write
a recursive CTE to do it is the
structure of your data continuously
evolving one of the real strengths of
graph databases is their flexibility
when it comes to data and schema we'll
talk about that here in a few minutes
but it it allows for the continuous
evolution of your data and your schema
much easier than a relational database
and is your domain a natural fit for a
graph is it is it one of those ones we
talked about or one of the ones you can
find online if you can answer yes too
many you know probably two of these
questions you probably have a good good
fit for a graph database so now the next
natural question comes down to can't you
just do this in sequel well the answer
is yes I mean none of the questions I've
brought up yet have them something that
hasn't already been resolved in a sequel
at least once or twice by people so
let's take a look at it let's take a
look at the Northwind data model I mean
we've all probably seen the Northwind
data model so many times we know it by
heart at this point but here's a
comparison of what a simplified
Northwind data model schema looks like
in a relational database and then in a
graph database
so let's shoot what does a simple search
or selection look like well a simple
search or selection query you know
pretty straightforward sequel queries
you know give me these values from this
table with a symbol inner join between
the two this is the comparable gremlin
and cipher to match that same to answer
that same question as you can see
there's probably you know this is a
really straightforward sequel a sequel
query probably don't necessarily need to
use the power of a graph database to
answer this question as I said it can
work it can't answer it probably not
necessarily what you want to do in the
first step you know give me the top five
order products this is an aggregation
type query same sort of thing still
pretty straightforward sequel I'm
guessing probably everybody in this room
has no problem writing this sequel
without even looking up what syntax this
is you know it's a simple select top
with a couple of inner joins in an order
by if you look at the gremlin and them
in the cipher yet again it's pretty
straightforward all you're doing is
basically defining what sort of pattern
you want to find in the graph and then
returning the values this is where you
start seeing the power of of a graph
database I want to find products that I
that I haven't are purchased by other
people that I have yet purchased yet so
what you're starting to run into where
these sequel queries start becoming not
fun to write not fun to maintain and not
particularly perform it you know this is
an interior this is a Select inside of
select with multiple group and order
buys multiple where Clause as multiple
joins under takes a while to sit down
and just understand and read what this
is for anyone trying to figure this out
don't worry I'll share the slide so you
can actually look at them in detail
because the text gets very small in
order to fit in on a slide if you look
at the gremlin or the cipher query as
you can see they're much simpler they're
much easier to read they're much more
fluid to be able to read through this
information to pull out the data in fact
about on the gremlin query it's only the
first four lines that actually answer
the question the last three lines are
just pulling out and grouping the data
and on the cipher query it's only the
first three lines it takes to answer the
question and the last three lines are
for grouping and ordering by
this one is this one is not a north wind
data model query but this is an example
of how you can take a recursive CTE and
make it a far easier query in a graph
this is basically I want to see all my
employers supervisors and the levels so
the way you do this in sequel is you
basically have a you know a temporary
table with a recursive CTE that's
filling that table as it's looping
through an unknown number of times in
order to get from you or to get from an
employee to the top of that that
employees management chain I don't know
if any of you have ever had to write
these or maintain them they're not fun
they're near impossible to get right no
one knows how they work and they're
magic until they don't work and then you
lose all your hair trying to figure it
out as you can see the gremlin on the
the other side is far easier to read far
easier to maintain and actually far more
performant because recursive CTS are
extremely are strongly not performing
they chew up your database resources and
the actually the current project I'm
working on is replacing our family tree
which was written in sequel using
recursive CT ease with gremlin for this
specific reason it scales but it allows
us to scale better it allows us to take
some load off of our sequel server
that's serving are the rest of our
application so now that you know a bit
about the use cases for a databases and
a bit about what you may and may not
want to do with it where do you start
well the logical place to start is
choosing your datastore you know this is
where you kind of have to make an
initial decision are you gonna do you
know is your problem a framework problem
is it an RDF problem is it a property
model problem our label property model
graph problem what sort of high
availability requirements do you have
what sort of transaction volume do you
have what sort of data size are you
dealing with the answer to those
questions will really tell you whether
you're able to work with a database
that's that fits on a single server
whether you need one that has a single
server with read replicas or whether you
need a fully distributed system
all of those exist for any of those
things if you can get away with doing it
on a single server you're obviously
gonna have far less headache then if you
have to do go on the fully distributed
method but the fully distribute method
gives you high availability things and
other things and then you want to do a
hosted around premise as far as I'm
aware there is hosted versions of many
of the data stores I showed up there
probably at least a quarter to a third
of them have a hosted version out
somewhere as I mentioned Amazon AWS has
Neptune that actually just went general
availability about a week ago or two
weeks ago cosmos DB has a gremlin API on
top of it there's other ones out there
for there's hosted versions of neo4j
there's hosted versions of on attacks
any of the graph frameworks can be used
on top of almost all of the graph
frameworks use Apache spark under the
covers Apache spark is a hosted product
in several places and you can run it on
top of that so what are some of the
concerns you have when thinking about a
datastore data consistency with
relational databases you get you the
data consistency that's known as acid
consistency stands for atomic consistent
isolated and durable basically what it
means is as soon as your data is written
it's a very pessimistic way to actually
do data consistency because but what it
guarantees you as soon as your data is
written that data is consistent across
everything and will always be there it's
been written it's been durable it's been
durably written to disk and it's
consistent across everything in no
sequel data stores a lot of them have
made trade-offs of consistent are of for
higher availability that have made
trade-offs to other parts of the of acid
compliance it comes the one you'll see
out there light is it's called base
compliance I know I didn't come up with
a name but yes you know it stands for
base availability so the system is
available almost all of the time it's
got soft state which means that you're
not necessarily write consistent or read
consistent but that you're eventually
can in the e stands for eventual
consistency which means that that of
that data will eventually become
consistent across all the different
areas so knowing whether you need acid
compliance or not or what parts of
see compliance you need really will help
aid in your figuring out which data
store you want to use because if you
need full asset compliance there are
certain data graph databases out there
that's that provides that and if you
need it you've automatically narrowed
your search down from 43 to a very small
number once you kind of have that that
number once you kind of are able to
narrow down your choices to a smaller
number really explore those choices each
of the choices have very different pros
and cons to them if anyone has any
specific questions we can come talk to
me afterwards but I don't have time to
go through them all of all of the
different pros and cons of all of them
here but really explore your choices
understand what you're choosing and what
you're giving up by doing that by that
choice and then beware the operational
overhead craft databases I don't want to
say they have more operational overhead
than their relational databases but
their operational overhead is can be non
it can be non insignificant especially
if you're dealing with highly
distributed ones it's also something
that is not familiar to most most
organizations most organizations have
DBAs or people that act as DBAs or
people that have done DBA work in the
past and know how to make those systems
run graph databases nobody has that guy
that everyone has to learn that you know
somebody on the team has to be the guy
that has to learn all of those things in
order to make it work so make sure you
take you factor that in when you're
making your decision so once you kind of
made the choice as to what data store
you're gonna use it's time to do a
little bit of data modeling the
statement you'll often see about graph
database modeling for graph databases is
it's whiteboard friendly this is really
true and that's because your your data
model in your graph because it so
naturally fits into the real world
domain tends to be very close to your
conceptual model I always say I always
kind of put a little qualifier on there
and say it really needs to be a
pragmatic conceptual model because in
ideal world you could basically take
your conceptual model and make it your
graph data model in the real world you
have to apply the fact that your graph
database stores data in certain ways it
has certain optimizations that or
certain optimizations or features that
it has
have that you really need to take into
account when you're working with your
conceptual model or with your conceptual
model when you're when you make that
India graph data model you also have to
take into account how you're going to
traverse your data so one of the things
with a graph data is the performance of
your query is going to be directly
related to the amount of the graph that
you actually query at any one time in
order to answer your question if you
query a hundred nodes and edges in order
to answer your query it's gonna take
twice as long as if you query 50 so if
you're able to make your model if you're
able to know that the queries you're
most likely to be hitting are the ones
you hit most often and you're able to
optimize your model in some ways for
that it's definitely something you want
to look at if you have nothing you know
if you're starting from an existing
system and you don't really know where
to start but the first thing I'd suggest
you do is just migrate your relational
model if you migrate your relational
model across it will work what you want
to do then on either whether you want
migrate your relational model across or
which you start with your own conceptual
model is really iterate iterate iterate
on actually on your data model iterating
on your data model is a really common
practice in graph data modeling that
isn't quite as common in the relational
data model a lot of big enterprise is in
a relational model you kick the data
modeling over to another team that team
does their work send you back this is
the data model you're going to use and
you go and build your application in a
graph data world you really have to be
able to has to be a much more
interactive because as I said knowing
how you're traversing your data directly
affects your query performance so being
able to iterate on that data model to
get the most performant and optimized
model for your system is something you
really need to make sure you you build
into your plan things to be concerned
about in data modeling um the one that
almost every you almost every new graph
datum our new person to graph does that
I see consistently is what's known as
symmetric relationships so in graph data
modeling most graph data modeling all
the great data stores use what's called
directed edges that means that you have
an inverted hex and an out vertex to the
edge goes from one vertex in your system
to another vertex in your system
what you'll see a lot of people
especially new to graph do is they'll
put one edge that goes from you know
vertex a to vertex B and an edge occurs
from vertex B to vertex a that both
represent the same logical construct
integral just because the edge has a
direction doesn't mean you need to you
can only traverse it in that direction
so you can traverse an edge both of the
in direction in the out direction so
there's no need to duplicate that
relationship so you don't need to use
symmetric edge relationships if the edge
if there's an edge going between two
vertex is in both directions and they
mean the same thing get rid of one of
them
the next thing to always think is to
look out for what I call hidden or
anaemic relationships this will happen
especially if you migrate your
relational database directly across your
relational database model directly
across so what is it a hidden or an emic
relationship well let's go back to that
initial constructs I talked about where
you had an order table a products table
in an order details table if you
migrated that straight across you'd have
three different vertexes I'll you have
two different types of edges those none
of those edges would have any properties
about them they would have no metadata
on because because you now have a graph
model those graph you can get rid of
that one vertex and put those properties
on to that as edges which will make that
edge and you know a fully-fledged part
of your graph
additionally adding those properties to
the edges can be a way to speed up your
query because if you have to go you know
as opposed to having go from a vertex to
an edge to a vertex to answer our
filtering question I can go from a
vertex to an edge so I've now just
topped out 50% of my traversals I can
answer that quite I can filter in and
out traverse in there now nodes quicker
if you're able to put those properties
on the edges one of the other things
you'll hear about when you hear about
graph data modeling is this concept of a
super node a super node is often
referred to as the justin beaver node it
what it is is it's a node in a graph
that has a disproportionately high
number of incident edges to the other
graph surrounding I know that problem
made no sense to anybody that just what
I said so let me explain it a little bit
so an incident edge in a graph is a
graph an edge that either is coming in
or going
out of a note pretty straightforward a
super node is when you have one node
that contains like ten or a hundred or a
thousand times more edges than the
average and why does that a problem
or well let me give you an example of it
a really common example I like to use
for this is addresses let's say you have
an address and you have a country
associate with that address if you
wanted to be you know if you want to be
a purist of graph day of graph theory
and graph modelling that country would
be its own node but let's say you're in
Norway and maybe you shipped to Norway
and Sweden let's say you've shipped 150
million orders well now you're gonna
have a hundred and fifty million edges
either going into or going out of Norway
or Sweden notes like there's a lot
that's gonna be drastically more than
anything else in your graph and it's
gonna return a problem if you want to
basically filter down data based like a
filter or have traversals that go
through that node to filter out data so
if you want add answer questions like
what's the country for this address
you'd be ok because you're only doing
you're following a single edge incident
are you fine
a single edge in to get one piece of
data but if you want to say filing every
order that's been placed in this city
inside Sweden you'd start in Sweden edge
then you'd look out 75 million orders
and then you'd have to filter it down
after that as you can see that's quickly
gonna become a very non performant query
or not perform a traversal so in that
sort of scenario a lot of times what you
end up doing is you'll denormalize that
data onto that edge said this is kind of
where that pragmatic part of your data
modelling needs to come in where you're
looking at the way you're going to query
your data and adjusting your model
accordingly schema schema is kind of a
hot topic in in graph the graph world if
you go out and you read most of the data
literature or most of the the sales
literature on you know data stores
they'll talk about how there's ski our
graph datastore a lot of them will talk
about how their schema lists and how the
schema can constantly evolve that's true
I'm not necessarily saying that having
that ability is bad but you're if you if
your data store doesn't enforce a set of
schema maya my suggestion is to make
your applications enforce it and why is
that
because if I have seven different
applications writing to the same graph I
don't want to go out seven different
edges to find out what product was
ordered by somebody because application
a called it one thing an application be
called it a different thing just for the
act just for the simplicity of the of
the thing enforce that schema at your
application level and because you're
doing that you can make it general
because the fact that you have the
ability to add properties on top of
those edges you can most of the time
instead of adding specific edges you can
add more general edge with a property of
a type or something like you know maybe
you have a person with phone numbers
well ince opposed to having a home phone
address a work phone address a mobile
phone sorry not address a home phone
edge a work phone edge a mobile phone
edge you can make a single the edge that
just cuz has phone and it has different
types inside of it it allows you to
answer questions like give me all the
phone numbers for somebody or give me
only the mobile phone number for
somebody just as easily and much more
performant than trying to do it with
three or four different edges so what
next now I told you a little bit about
you know how to what to think about when
you choose a data store which thing
about when you kind of do your data
modeling unfortunately until you choose
your data store what's next is really
dependent what comes next is very is
really understanding what the data store
can do for you understanding the
constraints of that data store or
understanding the feature set it offers
you know certain ones that offer things
like unique constraints others don't
understanding that stuff is really what
needs to be what you need to work
through next and since there isn't
really a general statement can't go into
too much detail so kind of give a little
bit of a summary what are the good
things about graph databases I mean I
just spent the last probably 30 minutes
here telling you why not to use a graph
database but as I said I'm I like graph
databases I think they're very good at
solving problems
part of that is graphs are really
flexible it's very easy and generally
it's very easy to extend your model to
add additional attributes to add objects
allowing you know your data to your data
in your data schema to evolve at a rapid
pace that
isn't easily done inside a relational
database they're really great at
searching for relationships between
items but if that's not what you want to
show search they're probably not the
right solution they're a natural fit for
many domains and in those domains you'll
find the things you know it's much
easier and more natural to work through
a graph database than it is to
necessarily try and force that into a
relational database you know I always
think of the relational database it's
the old the old idiom that if you know
all you have is a hammer everything is a
nail well hopefully you know that
relational database is our is our hammer
we've all used that hammer we can put
whatever we want we can use whatever we
we can put whatever we want into it
doesn't make it the right tool for the
job you know hopefully what you'll get
out of this talk is at least a little
bit of an understanding of what graph
databases are good for and now you have
another tool when you'll tool about for
when it's the right choice what are some
of the bad things about graph databases
well the different options about graph
databases scale very differently it's
very specific to the data store
unfortunately there's no like rule of
thumb I can give you where if you have
this size thing you want this specific
thing the team working on early has to
learn a new mindset it's a different way
of thinking looking at your data it's a
different way of thinking about your how
you query your data and it takes times a
tie takes teams time to learn that and
it's still a very immature space as I
said you know it's constantly evolving
it's very the tooling is not as mature
as some is what we're all used to for
relational databases I mean relational
databases have been around for in their
current form probably about 40 or 50
years now they obviously have
optimizations that far exceed what
exists in the graph data space you know
the graph dated space has been around
maybe 10 12 years for the property model
graphs the tooling out there is nowhere
near as robust it's now in near ease
easy to use I like to think of graph
databases is kind of like teenagers you
can eventually get what you need out of
them but sometimes it seems a lot harder
than you actually want it to be oh you
think it should be and then the ugly so
the ugly part is really the lack of
documentation there's lots of really
good documentation out there for people
that are brand-new to graph databases
and people that are expert at graph
there's really a lack of good
documentation for people that know a
little bit but not enough it's an area
that's really had there's a there's a
big hole that I'm hoping to work with
people to help fill that hole the
ecosystem is vast it's splintered and
it's rapidly evolving because of the
immaturity of the space and because it's
not as well defined set of standards and
things like that it changes all the time
as I said it's very hard to keep up with
some of the paces and you know the other
part here is hopefully it's helped a
little bit but it's kind of hard for new
users to tell good use cases versus bad
use cases usually the way you do it is
by making the wrong choice so here's
some of my advice from kind of the
trenches you know graph data stores may
be great to solve your problem but
really make sure you understand what
your problem is first make sure you
expect when you're planning out and you
know a date an application development
plan or application development
lifecycle make sure you build in time
for trial and error there's gonna be a
lot of trial and error you may start
with one data store and find out it's
not really the right choice for you and
you need to switch to a second one you
may need to do that to a third one
make sure you plan in time to do that
your data model is going to evolve plan
for it you know as I said it's not you
know a lot of enterprise applications
that you know data models are kind of
set by a different team and then that's
just what you build against that's not
really the way it works in a graph
database at least not the way to get an
efficient data model don't underestimate
the time it takes your team bring your
team up speed I've been guilty of making
this mistake with teams I've worked with
is thinking you know oh this will take
them a week and it takes some two months
as I said there's not a lot of great
documentation out there sometimes the
tooling is a lot harder it's a lot more
immature it a lot of it's very specific
to a single to a single data store so if
you use data store and you learned how
to use that tool and now you can figure
it out that's not the right one you got
to go to a different data store that has
a different set of tools that you need
to learn how to use and you know graph
databases are in a silver bullet you'll
go out there and you'll see if you go
out on the web you'll see lots of things
where people are claiming that craft
databases will solve all your problems
and everything's you know unicorns and
rainbows reality is there
good for some things they're not as good
for other things and being able to kind
of understand that and be able to say
maybe this isn't a good use for a graph
database or maybe this part of this
problem is good or use for a graph
database and this part is I want to use
my relational database for so really
common pattern I've run into is to use a
some sort of graph database as part of a
polygon persistence mechanism so that's
everything I had for you guys today are
there any questions so the question was
is it common to see a part of a report
reporting or a data warehouse database
data lake something like that being
written in a graph database actually
usually I don't see that written to a
graph database as much is usually the
way I've seen that done is it's written
someone uses a graph framework to do
processing on it and then stores the
results of that processing out to a
relational database
sometimes a graph database but usually
most of the big heavy number crunching
is done with a framework because
especially we start talking about very
large data warehouses are very large
data lakes it's a lot it can be a lot of
data and it can be depending on the
question trying to answer it can take a
lot of time to process through it
anybody else
so the question was is query time
predictable across the number of notes
the answer to that question is in most
cases yes it is sort of I mean like
anything else it's a computer if you
have 90 things running on the computer
and you don't have enough CPU power no
but basically given everything being
equal yeah you can usually assume that
twice as money did much data is going to
take twice as long to process I know
it's a loaded question so the question
was is scaling the only thing I used to
differentiate when choosing a graph
database which graph database I choose
it's not the only thing I use but it's
definitely a very it's definitely one of
the biggest concerns because if you want
something that has high availability
well that immediately removes certain
ones that don't support that sort of
thing if you need if you have something
that has you know transactional you know
extremely high read and write trends a
right transaction level certain
databases don't support you know
multiple right replicas the other option
is you know what if there's familiarity
in the team as far as any familiarity
with graph databases you know I know
like there was one person up here that's
used neo4j for so if all else being
equal if we have familiarity on the team
of some that actually knows how to use
this product I would probably choose the
product that they know over other
products and the other one that comes
down to is licensing costs as always you
know things cost money what's what's the
expertise of the team just so you know
on that that slide show I that slide
that showed all the graphs databases
that is a combination of both commercial
and open source some of those are open
source some of those are commercial some
of those have open source versions of a
commercial product so it's kind of a
there's a variety of different options
out there that you can use to help make
that decision as well
anybody else okay then thank you very
much
if anybody has any questions or wants
any more specific details feel free to
come on down and talk to me
you